Not an established podcast, a new podcast.
So we're recording this for Peak Mind.
I'm with my co-host and younger brother, Matthew, or Matt.
And our guest today is Morgan Farrell of Intuitive Underground.
How are you doing, Matt?
I'm good.
How are you, JT?
All right.
So welcome, Morgan.
Thanks for coming on again.
Like JT said, we have a few prepared questions.
And then as we continue, I'm sure that I'll have, you know, some more questions as things come up.
So the first question of the day is we'd like you to tell us about a remote viewing project that excited you and take us through the steps of that project.
So thank you.
Okay.
Sure thing.
Thanks for having me on, guys.
Okay.
One that excited me, well, there's no shortage on that list to draw from, but, you know, something that comes to mind, and, you know, there are different projects that are exciting for different reasons, right?
Um, but let's, let's jump way back in time to probably, I'd say about, uh, the three-week mark, uh, in, uh, in my training.
And at that time, one of the exercises that I was given was to work front-loaded.
Now, uh, I think you guys understand, but just, just, uh, to be clear in case anyone listening, um, doesn't, doesn't really understand what remote viewing looks like.
Uh, just briefly, so typically a, uh, project manager or a trainer, uh, in this case, uh, as I was a student at the time, um, typically will select a specific designated target.
We call it a discrete target, and that target will typically be any person, place, thing, or event.
Um, generally for training purposes, it would be in, in real time, or, uh, in the past.
Uh, in other words, uh, uh, a target that is readily verifiable for feedback purposes, for the sake of learning, right?
So we can easily identify what data the viewer gets correct, uh, and where they need improvement.
So, uh, about three, maybe three to four weeks into, uh, into my training, one of the lessons that, um, I was, I was working on was, uh, introduction to predictive work, future predictions.
And it was, uh, there was a second lesson in there, and that was actually working what we call front-loaded.
So, in other words, front-loaded means that the viewer actually has some, uh, indication as to the nature of the target.
Now, the act of being front-loaded as a viewer can be on somewhat of a spectrum.
Anywhere from, you know, the, the tar, uh, something as simple as the target is a person.
So that doesn't narrow it down a whole lot.
It excludes a lot of other possibilities, but nonetheless, um, and it just, it acts as a way sometimes to get the viewer to focus right away on the information that, that we're actually after.
As opposed to if I was fully blind and the target was a person, I would still pick up on that person and describe them as intended.
However, I'm, I would be more likely to pick up on maybe additional, uh, contextual data.
So, the lesson, uh, that I was working, as I mentioned, was how to work front-loaded and how to work against future targets, predictive intelligence.
And this specific, uh, lesson is actually pretty cleverly designed because the nature of the front-loading is such that there is absolutely no possible way
the, the, the student could ever guess what the target is going to be.
So, what we did was I was tasked to remote view, um, the primary photo on the front page of a specific newspaper.
And at this time, um, we were still dealing in, uh, physical newspapers.
So, what I would do is I would work the target and then the next morning I would walk down to the corner store
and I would look at their newspaper rack for my, for my feedback.
Um, so the first, the first one that I ran was, it was actually a pretty decent session,
but there was, there was actually a piece of the target queue that I didn't realize I, I had excluded.
And so, at this time, um, I was a member of, uh, Major Ed Dame's old, uh, rvcommunity.net, uh, training forums.
So, I uploaded my results for critique and someone pointed out to me the, uh, the missing, uh, what we would call a qualifier
in the targeting strategy or the queue.
So, that night, uh, I went back and I amended my targeting strategy by adding this additional qualifier
and, um, uh, I guess I won't bother getting too off into the weeds with, with that stuff, but...
No, I mean, go ahead.
If, if it's, if it's relevant to how a session works, then we should definitely hear it.
Um, you know, I mean, it is, but really only at a, at a higher level.
Fair enough, fair enough.
Yeah, I just, I don't want to introduce too much, uh, confusion in terminology.
That's, uh, something I, some, I'm cognizant of, uh, sometimes I do that.
So, the point is, I, I sat down and I ran a second session and I, of course, I did the same thing.
I just, well, I don't have my feedback yet and I won't until first thing tomorrow morning.
So, I went down, uh, next morning, probably about 8 a.m. to the corner store and lo and behold,
um, there's, uh, there's the photo that I remote viewed and it was really, really bang on,
um, visually, uh, and not just in terms of data.
The data was, it was quite accurate, maybe a little sparse in terms of, of detail, uh,
at that time, but just the visual representation was, it was absolutely uncanny.
And what was it, Morgan?
Uh, the photo at that time was Queen Elizabeth giving an address from the deck of a ship and
she was waving out at the, out at the crowd.
Oh, cool.
Um, yeah, I still have that session somewhere.
So, uh, I could, uh, I can show you sometime.
I'd have to take it out, but, um, yeah, I do have a copy of it, um, somewhere in my digital
archives anyhow.
Um, but yeah, that was, um, that was really something else, um, because, you know, it's one
thing to have seen other people do similar things and to believe, or even to know that
it's possible.
Um, but then to, to actually have done it for yourself and to really know it's possible is,
that was something else.
So that was a, yeah, that was a major, uh, peak, I guess you'd say on my learning curve.
Like for those who are, who are listening, um, who aren't in, um, some sort of predictive
discipline, right.
Um, you're not an astrology, you're not a remote viewer, you're not, um, in any type of, in
any type of forecasting.
It's a very common thing for people who are even, um, well-educated and very experienced
in the subject, even like famous remote viewers, famous, uh, astrologers, et cetera, to not fully
believe in remote viewing or astrology or whatever they're doing.
And you'll see somebody who is like well-known and people hang on their every word and then
they'll run a session and something will happen, right?
Like an RV session and they'll predict an event and the event will come to pass and they'll
be like, Oh my God, I can't believe it.
And most of their fans will kind of, they just will gloss over that and not pay much attention,
but to a critical observer, it's like, Whoa, what are you, what are you doing?
If you don't, if you don't actually like a hundred percent believe what you're doing,
why are you, um, you know, why are you disseminating this information?
It's just sort of one of these funny things.
Um, one of my, uh, I'm no one to him, right.
But, uh, one of, uh, uh, my nemeses, because he's, uh, you know, well, for different reasons,
uh, Dan Waits of world astrology report, right?
So we all have like that person that we compete with or like in our minds, even if we're not
actually competing with them in reality, or we see them as a challenge in some way in our
minds, even if that's not actually something that's occurring in reality, right?
So we've had interactions for years on social media and, uh, sometimes things that I talked
to him about in social media back in the day would wind up in his videos.
And, you know, when you're, when you're, when you don't have influence, when you're not an
influencer today, um, you're not seen really as a source.
And if you're not seen as a, as a primary source, then, you know, your conversations can
be, regardless of your expertise can be seen almost like hearsay, right?
So like a cab driver, like this, this guy might be an expert, but you know, he doesn't have
a hundred thousand, uh, subs.
So it's just like hearing it from a cab driver.
I don't have to credit the cab driver.
I don't have to credit this random person on social media.
Okay.
Um, but that he, you know, he recently put out a video and the video was, um, I didn't
want to believe in astrology.
And then, you know, and I, I don't know, I'm just not really, uh, that that's, that's
not, uh, it's not something I really like that people do.
So, um, I don't want to, uh, detract too much, but, um, Morgan, I wanted to break this
down into two pieces.
One, I would love for you to tell us more about your documentation.
I know that sounds odd, but you have, I think, um, like the, the tightest, uh, documentation.
And I think people should know that, right?
I think that's something that should come up in your interviews because when you speak
about something, um, that happened in a session or a conversation following a session, like
you're not just spreading hearsay, or it's not just like an opinion because you have the
records of the conversations themselves.
You have the recordings of the conversations that happened prior to during and following
in many cases, at least the actual RV sessions.
So when it comes down to like, um, this viewer, their perception was, you know, that you guys
were talking about this and you know, how does that square with your perception that like,
there's no question there because you can draw the actual recording and say, no, this is
what you said.
This is what I said.
And I'd also like for you to think of if you can't go into the details cause you haven't
drawn the information from your, um, digital archives.
So you don't want to speak, um, extemporaneously and, um, and get some of the details wrong.
You could still tell us, I think, and that was exciting.
The queen, uh, the, the queen Elizabeth, I'm not taking away from that, but like, what
project have you run?
Right.
Cause we're going to talk a little bit about, about intuitive underground and what project
have you run?
That's really super exciting.
Like if you were in an elevator with Elon Musk or, you know, someone with a lot of money
and a lot of influence and they were like, dude, what's the, the craziest, most exciting,
um, RV project you've ever run.
Would it, what, I mean, I don't know if it would be the queen Elizabeth, would it?
I mean, it's a, it's a fair answer if it is.
Okay.
I see what you mean.
Well, you know, yeah.
Context, I suppose changes everything.
Um, that was exciting to me personally, just because it was, uh, it was a firsthand experience
and a, a little bit of a, it was a breakthrough, you know, not a small thing at all.
I'm just wondering, like, you know, like if you weren't talking to me, right.
If it wasn't just me and Matt, like if it was, you know, Elon Musk or, or, or the president
of the United States or someone else.
And they were like, why should we buy into this?
You know, RV, what's, what's the most exciting thing you've ever seen?
What's the project that really, you know, you'll always remember.
Okay.
Well, I mean, you know, to that end there, again, there's, there's really no shortage
to draw from there.
There, there isn't not a single one necessarily comes to mind, but I mean, I can give you a
couple of examples really, really briefly here.
Yeah.
We don't have to be brief because we have an hour, about an hour to go.
So.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well, I can also be very, very drawn out about it too.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah.
I'll start using like the sounds because we have sounds now we can clap and whatever.
I'll, I'll, uh, I'll give some sort of sound and that'll be the sign.
Okay.
Fair enough.
I'll try and be, uh, I'll try and be, uh, reasonable about it.
So.
Okay.
Well, again, it, it depends on the context, um, in terms, well, you know what, keep sticking
with the theme of, of predictive work.
And in fact, this one kind of, uh, ties nicely into a point, uh, that you just made a moment
ago and I'll get there in a second.
But, uh, with regards to predictive work, um, outside of a training scenario, probably the
first major predictive hit that we had was, uh, the 2016, uh, Trump election.
So we ran, we ran a project.
I was a viewer on this project.
Uh, I think there were myself and two other viewers and a project manager.
And we were tasked blind, uh, with a set of target reference numbers and my, my basic session
that I ran on this was, it was okay.
It was a little bit noisy.
Um, I didn't realize at the time, but I, and then I was asked to do a little bit of, uh, what
we would call follow on exploration, which is just to jump back into the session and to get
a little bit more, uh, specificity and detail on, uh, a specific element or a topic or a theme
or an item or whatever that's being identified in the basic session.
So in this case, um, I actually named Donald Trump.
Trump in, in my session, which is, it's relatively rare to actually name the target as, you know,
the, the axiom of remote viewing is sketch and describe don't name.
Um, however, in this case, I did actually named the target, uh, during the post session analysis
phase, while we were, uh, the team, we were all still other than the project manager, we
were still blind to the target and we had a round table, uh, debrief and analysis session.
We went around, you know, the three viewers presented our work and it was very, very obvious what
we were dealing with, um, just by, by the descriptions, uh, of the other viewer sessions.
And, and this one was, this was a case where any of the three viewers work stood on its own strong
enough to make a clear 100% prediction as to the outcome.
Uh, in a case like this, where all three sessions are that spot on that on target, there's absolutely no question.
Um, so this was, and just to give you an idea of the timeframe here, we're talking, this is
late February of 2016, um, at such a time, uh, Donald Trump running for the presidency was
still widely regarded as, as some sort of a joke or a publicity stunt.
Um, and I'll, I'll be the first to admit that I was very much of the opinion at that time
that, that it was probably nothing more than a publicity stunt.
Um, but it was, it was that session that really made me, I guess, take a step back and, and take
note and, uh, become a little more interested in what was actually going on there.
Um, not that I'm, uh, an overly political person, uh, in general, but, uh, and, and I think history
bore out the fact that, uh, yeah, that was, uh, that was a very interesting, uh, an unusual
time period that we are, uh, really we're still, uh, we're still in, uh, largely.
But, uh, yeah, that, that was a case where not again, not just based on my own session,
but the strength of all three combined, we made the call right then and there that, okay,
Trump is going to win the, uh, election in November and he's actually going to be the 45th president.
Um, we published that work, uh, I think it was early March by the time it actually got out
there, but, uh, you know, we, it was widely regarded.
We were widely regarded as of course being, uh, incorrect and et cetera, et cetera, as you
might guess, but no, we knew that we weren't and we stuck with our guns and, and we were correct.
Now here's the interesting part of the story that, uh, ties back to something you, uh, you alluded
to.
Um, and you're absolutely correct in your observation that a surprising, in fact, I think
many people would actually be shocked at the percentage of, of people actively involved in
a given, uh, field, uh, particularly things, uh, you know, kind of at the, at the margins
of, uh, you know, acceptable, the acceptable sciences, things like astrology, things like remote
viewing, um, but the amount of active practitioners in the field that, as you said, truly they don't
actually believe in what they're doing, uh, is surprisingly high.
And I had a firsthand experience based on this, this project.
Um, so later that year, uh, a, a former team member of ours, uh, in fact, came up here, uh,
to Canada, uh, to visit and stay at my place for a little while.
And he arrived at, uh, that was the end of October, maybe the start of November.
In any case, um, he was here visiting when the election was going on.
So we sat in my living room watching the results roll in live.
And I think it was about around 3:30 AM.
If I remember correct, uh, about 3:30 AM local time.
Uh, when the call, the official call was made that, uh, you know, this contest is over.
Uh, Donald Trump will assume the presidency and Hillary Clinton lost.
When the official word came in, uh, this individual, we were sitting on my couch.
I can, I can picture it in my mind's eye as, as, as clear as anything.
He looked over at me and he goes, I didn't think that was going to happen.
And my jaw nearly hit the floor because the first question naturally that popped in my head was,
well, then what, what are you doing this for?
Why did you bother tasking us against a target like that?
If you didn't believe that we were correct.
Right.
So now I know you're going to hate, hate the answer to this question, but, uh,
would you say that that individual could be categorized as having some fame in the remote
viewing community?
Uh, that would be fair to say.
Yeah.
So at least at one time, at least at one time.
Right.
So it goes right back to, to exactly what I said.
You're right.
Um, even people who are well-known, um, they, they don't necessarily buy or believe,
you know, back their own product, back their own.
Uh, interest.
So when you said, uh, people said you were wrong, um, I think you should elaborate on
that a little bit because if I remember correctly, part of this story might be that you ran into
a little hostility on a certain, um, social media app, not X.
And, um, and I was wondering, like, could you elaborate on the extent of the hostility
towards this prediction and how many people, uh, came back later and apologized or admitted
that they were wrong?
Oh yeah.
Well, to be fair, most of the public hostility we received was actually from our 2024 election
prediction, which, you know, other than, other than the year, um, the story was fairly similar.
Um, you know, we clearly none and unambiguously determined through our remote viewing results
that the Trump was going to win and, uh, maybe, or maybe not one of the, uh, viewers critical,
uh, in that prediction might be in the listening audience right now.
I don't know, but, uh, it was the, the pushback we received in the 2016 election, um, was,
it was more, uh, on a personal and individual level, uh, you know, uh, people that we know
in our, in our own lives, you know, our friends and family.
Oh, they didn't get you on the Reddit that time?
Not that time.
We didn't, we really didn't have much of any public presence at all at that time.
I mean, it, uh, we did publish our results, but, uh, no, the pushback we got, uh, in 2016
was mostly on, on a one-to-one kind of level.
Uh, but you are absolutely correct.
Um, when we did the 2024 election and published our results, uh, we received incredible pushback.
Um, I would, I would say this is just an off the cuff number, but I would say 80% or more
of the, uh, interactions we got, um, regarding that prediction were negative, very negative.
Yeah.
Uh, and so, and people are going to think, right.
They're going to say, well, why is he pushing on this point?
What difference does it make?
Or is it, is he being kind of juvenile?
No.
So this is why this is important.
Okay.
Uh, people, when, when you're in the predictive sciences, predictive arts,
whatever you want to call it, right?
Predictive metaphysics.
When, uh, you make a, an unpopular prediction, uh, people will respond to you oftentimes with
a lot of hostility.
They'll accuse you of being political, of being biased in some way of being a doom and gloomer,
right?
Why are you a doom and gloomer?
Generally speaking, the real reason that they're doing this is, is they don't want to accept the
possibility that something uncomfortable could happen, right?
Like it's, it's uncomfortable for them to think about.
It's also uncomfortable for them to face like a cause and effect chain that might be related
to whatever you're talking about.
Um, so, or they themselves are amongst the 40% of people who not only, um, aren't capable
of extra sensory perception, but aren't capable of believing that extra sensory perception is
real.
Um, however, when you're right, uh, oftentimes people will, you know, um, will, will actually
avoid speaking to you so you can make predictions for a long period of time.
I, I, I, I, this happened on X where there's another X personality, um, who I had made a
bunch of predictions too, and they came to pass.
And the result of those predictions coming to pass was, uh, I did not hear from that individual
for two to three weeks, uh, completely ghosted, no response, no anything.
And in that case, people will wait long enough until they don't have to acknowledge the fact
that what you predicted actually happened.
And then they'll attempt to resume communication with you.
So the whole thing is sort of, and so in your experience, Morgan, and that's a great example,
right?
Where you're making these political predictions, people are pushing back 80% of people the second
time, right?
And in your personal life, the first time, I don't know how many, how often do people contact
you and say, Hey, you know, I, I responded, uh, inappropriately.
I responded kind of hostilely.
I accused you of all kinds of things, wanting things to happen, being a doom monger, whatever
it is they accuse you of.
Right.
And then they contact you in later and they say, you know what?
You were right.
How often do you think that happens?
Well, I mean, again, I don't have, uh, any hard statistics on this, but if we were to,
if we were to take a guess, the percentage is likely, uh, likely a single digit number,
right?
Maybe very, very low double digits.
Right.
And so the reason that's important, um, beyond what I just said is when people, um, make a personal
assessment of the ability, and this happens in astrology all the time, when people make a
personal assessment, um, of whether they, you know, quote, believe or not, right.
They make their, it's a virtue signal.
Okay.
It's a, it's a form of conformity.
And when you try to prove to them, when you get stuck in that mentality of, I need to prove
to people that this is real, I need to prove to people that I can, I can make these predictions.
You can never prove that to people because the people who don't want to believe will, uh,
exercise all kinds of mental gymnastics, uh, to avoid admitting when you're correct.
And then later when they're addressing the subject again, when they look back right into
their own personal mental database, they won't see any examples to back up the fact that what
you're saying is correct, right?
They'll only see like either times when people prognosticators have been proven wrong, or they'll
they'll just blank out on the fact that, you know, somebody correctly predicted 20 or 30 things for
them and they just ignored it, or they go to the person or whatever, as a way of, of not having to
accept the reality.
And again, like I said, 40% of people can't, right.
And that's what you really have to understand is that some of these people, it's not malice.
It's that they, not only are they blind, right?
Not only are they missing a sense, but they're missing a sense to the, to the extent that they
can't believe it's real, right?
So like a blind person who was blind from, from birth has no reason to believe that sight
is real, except for the fact that everyone else they meet in their life, except maybe two other
people will tell them it's real.
But when you have 40 plus percentage of the population who will tell them, no, this is
definitely not real.
And they often, they're in academia, they're in medicine, they're in politics, they're in
law enforcement, they're in authority, then that person doesn't have to accept the fact
that they're missing this sense, right?
And they can go through life carrying this idea that these things aren't real, that it's not
possible, like remote viewing is impossible, astrology is impossible.
And, you know, you just got to kind of cut them loose.
Anyhow, I went off on a tangent there.
That wasn't part of our list of questions.
I think it was a very good example, though.
Before we move on to the next one, Matt, you want to jump in?
Do you have anything you'd like to ask about the process or?
Yeah, I guess what I'm sitting over here thinking about is, well, like, I guess the first question
I want to ask you, Morgan, is like, is what is your mission?
Like, what are you, what are you trying to do?
Like, what's the point of, of your group?
Like, what, what, what is your mission?
Yeah.
Hey, great question.
Um, our, well, I mean, our group mission and my own personal individual mission are,
they're very much in alignment.
They're maybe not quite identical, but, um, generally speaking, um, so our group,
uh, the intuitive underground, uh, the purpose of that group has always been to, well, I should,
I should maybe jump back a little bit and mention our, our group actually, we started
as a study group.
Um, we, uh, we were a group of, of students who had all started training and remote viewing
around the same time, you know, within a few months.
Um, we maybe had one guy that was about a year ahead of us.
And so group initially formed as, as a training group, a study group, just, uh, in order to
build, uh, our own skills.
And at such a time as we felt capable of taking on, uh, more operational type product or projects,
um, we kind of made that transition, uh, into, into being an operational group.
Now, the purpose of being a, uh, you know, a publicly accessible operational group who publishes,
um, our results, you know, we've always said, uh, we aim to use remote viewing to uncover information
that is either interesting and or important to the general public, or at least that we view that,
that way.
Uh, and that's really it.
Um, simply means of demonstrating, well, in fact, that's kind of the tagline on our website is
demonstrating the power of remote viewing.
Um, so basically we just, we use RV against a very wide variety of problem sets.
Um, predictive intelligence being one very, uh, one of our probably most important through lines.
Um, just kind of laying down the foundations in that track record, which, you know, as, as I said
at the time, and I said this to the guys, every time we publish a new report, especially a predictive
report, I said, this is going to, this is the foundation for, for what we're ultimately aiming
to do in the future.
And we're at a time now where we have, we have that, um, well established, well in place.
Um, so the kind of the B component to that is not just in demonstrating the power of RV,
um, and demonstrating, you know, what a, a well trained and experienced operator can do,
let alone a team of operators.
Um, but also to really try and, uh, instill into our, our listening audience, the point that
virtually, and again, you, there's some nuance to be had here, but generally speaking, you
know, anyone that takes real genuine interest in this very likely they are not of that 40%,
the JT, uh, alludes to that's incapable, um, of experiencing extrasensory perceptions.
Um, so the ultimate point is to demonstrate to those people that you ultimately, if you so choose,
and if you choose to dedicate, uh, the time and effort, you can, you can do this for yourself.
You don't need us to tell you what's coming down the pike.
You can do it for yourself.
And I view that as, for lack of a better term, that's, it's kind of like a, it's a force multiplier.
Okay.
Um, the father, or some might argue the grandfather of remote viewing, uh, Ingo Swann,
he wrote, uh, a series of two books.
There was a third volume in the works, but it, it was never published.
Um, I'm not sure how far along the manuscript was, uh, when Ingo passed.
Um, so I doubt we'll ever see, uh, the third volume, but, uh, volumes one and two are called
secrets of power and they really kind of center around putting real power, uh, back into the
hands of, of individuals who, you know, let's face it are generally broadly powerless in,
in the, in the power structure we exist in, in the societal structure we exist in.
And that whole mindset has really been really kind of, uh, the driving force, I guess,
behind basically everything I do, uh, in this field, in remote viewing.
Um, you know, it's, it's the simplest way to put it.
It's the old, uh, give a man a fish or teach a man to fish, right?
Ultimately, where does the, where's the individual empowerment come from?
It comes from the individual learning how to do these things for themselves.
And, you know, there is a saying, um, that used to go around in the, uh,
in the older days of remote viewing.
And that was that remote viewing represents, um, at its best, a world without secrets.
And a world without secrets is good for a lot of people, but it represents a significant threat
to many others.
Well, allow me to ask you a question then.
Um, so your mission is to encourage people to seek remote viewing training.
Now we know there's a certain percentage of people that won't be ultimately successful for,
although it seems as if those people may be more successful than I would assume.
Um, but we do know that there are some people that do really well, right?
There are superstar remote viewers.
And this is actually kind of important because, um, right now the remote viewing community is
experiencing sort of a bifurcation where for a long time, you've had superstar remote viewers
sort of at the epicenter, whether you want to see it as the top of the pyramid or the bottom of the
funnel.
And everyone else who trains, who follows them, who's a fan ends up serving the purpose of either,
whether you want to look at the metaphor of passing things up or passing, you know,
or funneling things down to them, right?
Um, the real work, right?
So, uh, somebody can train, but they might not be that great.
Right now.
I know that, you know, of course you can correct me, but I believe that you've only had one,
you know, one student who really became professional remote viewer.
And so how to, okay, to perfect.
Thank you for correcting me.
So you had two students who became professional remote viewers.
Out of all your students, however many that is.
I'm sure, you know, the exact number, but okay.
So how do you see, how do you square your mission of, um, encouraging people to pursue this
right for themselves and the empowerment of the individual through remote viewing?
How do you, how do you balance that against the fact that a certain number of people are going
to be superstar remote viewers, right?
So, I mean, I think some people might say 10%, but that's not true.
Honestly, we're talking about 1%, 0.1%, 0.01%, right?
Like who knows exactly what the percentage is, but there are people who might be,
I think not technically as strong as you, like on the technical details, but who might have
greater psychic aptitude, right?
But most people are never going to reach up to the level of, of being somebody who can join
intuitive underground as a remote viewer, right?
And it's not like one, it's not even like one out of a thousand.
So your mission is to inspire people to pursue remote viewing training.
But how do you square that with the fact that it's people like you who are capable of discovering
the secrets of the universe and maybe the average person isn't?
Yeah, sure.
Um, there's actually, there's some really important stuff there.
Um, I think to answer your question most directly, and is it ironic if I answer it most directly
by way of analogy, um, I would say it's actually there, there are a lot of surprisingly or, or not,
there are actually a lot of parallels, uh, between remote viewing in this context and well,
virtually any other skill, but my, my background, uh, a lot of it is, is in music and there's, um,
there's a, there's a direct parallel to draw there.
And that is that, you know, just because someone wants to learn guitar
doesn't necessarily, they're going to be, you know, they're not going to be a rock star.
As you said, maybe it's one in a thousand has that capability.
Nonetheless, try and find someone who has spent a little bit of time learning guitar,
who regrets it.
There is value to be had there.
And to, to take this a little further, um, you know,
you mentioned the fact that there are, you know, a certain small, very small percentage
of students who become absolute all star remote viewers.
Uh, I'm not one of them.
I am not one of the greatest remote viewers ever.
Absolutely not.
And I would never say that I am.
What I am is a very well trained and experienced operator who's put in the work to get decent.
So I, I often describe my own, um, my own, uh, remote viewing as utilitarian, right?
It's not the prettiest.
It's not the most detailed.
Uh, it's, you know, it's, I don't have the highest accuracy rating, uh, on earth, but I do have, um,
general long-term reliability, uh, which is to say that, you know, as often as not, I can, I can solve a
problem on my own.
Um, when I'm part of a team, uh, you know, of guys of, of my skill level or, or better.
Uh, ideally, um, there's not a whole lot we can't do.
Um, some of the technical limitations, uh, are actually more associated with, uh, you know,
my level of, of expertise, um, outside of remote viewing.
So for example, I'm not a doctor, I'm not an engineer.
Um, but I can use RV to solve engineering problems, uh, to solve medical issues.
Uh, it's just, it's going to be, it's going to take a little bit more time on my part to figure
out exactly what my session work is saying, because I have to, I have to do the research,
you know, a great example would be, uh, well, I don't know what the censorship regime is like
these days, but a certain, uh, medical intervention that was introduced in late 2020, we looked into,
you know, some of the, uh, potential outcomes of, of that, uh, campaign.
And we came up with, uh, a number of items, uh, to look out for.
And, uh, it was my job as the, uh, report writer in that case to translate what we had in our remote
viewing work into proper, uh, medical scientific language.
That was probably the most difficult report I've ever written.
Uh, it probably took me somewhere between seven to 10 days of basically full time doing nothing else.
Um, just to ensure I was using terminology that was in some cases completely unfamiliar to me,
um, prior to that project, uh, that I was using that terminology correctly.
Um, I'm, I'm fairly satisfied with the, with the job I did there, but that's all to say,
you know, if we had a trained MD or a PhD on staff, well that, you know,
they could probably have, have turned that into a report in inside of a day.
So yeah, I'd like to hop in here for a second and just tell everyone, um, since the, you know,
Morgan brought up the subject, um, the two main, the, the, um, the, the excerpt, the summary,
uh, the report, whatever you want to call it.
Uh, the reason I, I don't know exactly whether it's called a report or something else is that
there are two sections or there were two sections on your website, right?
There were reports and there was something additional reports that I'm blanking on right
now.
I assume it's under the report section, but it's in one of the sections.
Yeah.
Everything is now consolidated under reports.
Perfect.
Okay.
So the report.
So, uh, if you go to intuitive underground.com, you can read that report.
It is free.
Um, I can give you a brief summary, which is, uh, they predicted, um, uh, some sort of dialysis
treatment, which is, um, something that's happening right now in Japan.
Under a scientist called Kevin McKiernan and is being, uh, or is beginning to be widely,
um, copied, um, in, uh, the Middle East, uh, where rich people go for the, a similar treatment
or in the U S where there's like a less effective version of the treatment, but that was predicted
in the IU material, um, years ago before anyone talked about it.
Um, that, uh, treatment for the, and I'm going to mention it because I, they can send to me all
they want spike proteins would be, uh, something involving like a dialysis treatment.
People pay about $30,000 to go to Japan.
They get it done there.
They go to the Middle East about 30 grand.
There's like, um, a knockoff treatment here.
It's about a grand.
They also in the report predicted that colloidal metals, uh, might be an effective treatment.
And there is at least one individual on X who is doing very well for himself promoting colloidal
zinc and copper as, um, in a certain ratio as something that, uh, can treat, uh, long COVID.
Uh, now I'm not a doctor, so I can't say, you know, whether it works or not.
Um, but I can't say that it was in RV data.
It was predicted prior to it occurring, um, years in advance, uh, by the intuitive underground data.
So that, that is there and anyone can go and, and take a look at it.
Uh, yeah.
So, okay.
So that's a great example though, right?
Because what you're basically saying is like your, your mission is have everyone empower themselves.
And I think it's a great mission at the same time, like, you know, very few people could
have, even if you look at yourself as a utilian utilitarian viewer, right?
You're still one in a thousand or, or, or, or, or less, right.
Or more or whatever, however that works.
Right.
And, um, you gave a great example of why, although heroic remote viewers like this vision of this
heroic, super psychic, right.
It's probably not the future.
Um, if we're looking to empower everyone at the same time, there is a place there, right?
So you're saying, well, if I was a doctor, I could have worked it out, but still you were
able to do something that no one else was able to produce.
So when you produce that report, nobody else had produced that information.
And that includes the doctors who were, um, promoting information,
although they were being resisted and censored on, um, on social media.
Right.
And that, that, I suppose that's ultimately my, my point, um, is that this is, uh, it's not,
uh, you know, it's not an elitist thing.
It's, um, it's available to everyone.
Um, especially those who make the choice to, to put in the work, uh, you know, it's necessary.
Pardon me?
An elite is necessary.
Well, if you, if you had that report, if you had left it right to your students, would
they have gotten the same information?
No, probably not, not quite, not yet.
Right.
So there has to be some sort of balance is all I'm saying, right.
There has to be a balance between the, um, the highly effective remote viewers and the
general population increasing.
It's, um, you know, the people can increase in their site ability.
I, um, I want to turn it back over to Matt, uh, for either the next question that he has
or the next question on the list, whatever he would prefer.
Yeah.
So, um, I guess my question was like, I mean, I, I understand it's not part of your mission
and maybe, maybe asking this question says more about me than anything, but like, what
would, what would stop somebody if they wanted to, for example, um, I don't know, like we have
this like poly market now.
And if I could just imagine that if you knew that Donald Trump was going to, um, win the
election, that, that there's probably way to like make money doing that.
I don't know if there's like a moral issue with that, but like, is it, can we, can we
use RV data to, to like make money?
Like, not necessarily to be a billionaire or anything, but I mean, at least enough to get
by, you know, to.
Yeah, this is a question that is a good question.
Right.
And the reason I'm jumping in is because Morgan specifically, uh, hasn't begun, uh, promoting
that type of, uh, session data, but other people do.
So if you're looking for that session data, there are, there's an ARV collective, um, that
kind of works on that.
There's future forecasting group there.
Um, there's, uh, dark predictions on, on YouTube.
Um, there are at least half a dozen well-known, uh, RV groups who, uh, they specialize in crypto,
which in my estimation, most crypto is a, is a pyramid scheme.
And I think it's because of the negative ethical connotations that groups like Morgan's group
don't, um, necessarily get involved in it.
But your question directly is, can people make money using remote viewing?
And the answer is yes.
The caveat is oftentimes people will, will hit a wall at some point.
And I think Morgan can explain that better as to exactly why intuitive underground hasn't
offered that service yet.
Yeah, no, it's a great question.
And, um, everything you said, JT is correct.
Uh, I mean, the short answer is can, can it be used for that purpose?
Yes, absolutely.
Um, and I, I, you know, even, uh, the specific example, Matt, that you, that you just, just
gave there about the, uh, uh, the 2016, uh, Trump prediction.
So our results were in, and we were fully confident in them early enough that, uh, uh, I believe
the odds were five to one against at that time.
And so maybe this is just a reflection of my own personality.
Um, you could argue it's a personality defect, but it literally didn't even cross my mind
to, to place a wager based on those results.
Um, however, I do know someone who did.
And, um, this person did very well for themselves on, on that one.
Uh, as I said, it was, uh, it was five to one, uh, odds against at that time.
Um, and that was locked in and I've seen, I've personally seen, uh, the slip, uh, for the
payout on that one.
Look, I'm not a remote viewer.
Um, I can tell you that, uh, going back years ago when this is relevant years ago, when, uh,
Holly field was fighting Tyson, I knew Holly field was going to kick his ass.
All right.
But I was the only person in America that I, that I was aware of at the time who seemed
to know that.
And the odds were 38 to one.
And that was like, they were being generous because they thought Tyson was going to kill
Holly field.
Right now, if I had a remote viewer now, I didn't place a bet cause I didn't know how to place
a bet.
I was just a kid, but if I had, I would have done very well.
So if somebody wanted to utilize remote viewing for that purpose, they certainly, they certainly
could.
Now, um, this is controversial.
So this is not Morgan saying this, and this is unconfirmed.
There are unconfirmed rumors that, uh, people around Jeffrey Epstein may have been trained
remote viewers.
Now I'm not, again, like that's very, um, it's a tough area to get into because once you
start talking about that, all you can think of is the horrible things, right?
The reason that's relevant is they won, um, they won the lottery twice.
And there is, there's speculation that they, uh, as a part of a training, right?
As part of their training and reviewing, they, they, uh, used it to win the lottery two times.
I don't know if it's true, but it's the best anyone can figure out as to how they did
that, but they did in fact, win the lottery two times.
Um, and there is definitely positive evidence that, uh, there were remote, there was remote
viewing involved in that community.
All right.
Thank you.
That's it.
You know, I probably shouldn't have even thrown it in there, but I thought it was interesting.
I don't know.
Yeah, absolutely.
I think my follow-up to this is, um, yeah, you're like relevant to the conversation of like
what it means to be a good remote, like somebody who maybe who's, who's more talented or, or
who has like risen to a level of expertise in remote viewing.
Like, do you track the hit rate?
Like how specific can you get?
I mean, in my experience with, um, and astrology, it's often very, um, I don't know.
It can be very like ambiguous and loose and riddled with metaphor, but your example is
very specific, right?
This person will win this election at this time, which is, you know, very falsifiable.
Right.
And so I'm just wondering, is the data that you're getting falsifiable in a way that you
can kind of track like a hit rate or something like that?
And is that something, um, that you do or, or, or is done?
Yeah.
Um, it can, it can be done.
Um, so there are a couple of ways that you can go about it.
Uh, first of all, you can, obviously you can, you can grade every single recorded perception
on a remote viewing transcript, um, in, in a case where you're working against something
with fully verifiable, uh, feedback available.
And, and that's, as I mentioned earlier, that's how we train, right?
We train against readily verifiable targets.
Um, it's really up to the individual, how, how in depth they want to get with that in
terms of, you know, coming up with a percentage of accuracy.
Um, my stance on that has always been, um, you know, that that's maybe useful for, uh, laboratory
work, you know, for scientific study, um, uh, from an operational standpoint.
And it's important to recognize that, uh, there are kind of two branches in, in RV, one
of them being laboratory study.
You know, they want to understand how it works, you know, figure out the mechanics, the physics
behind it.
If they can, um, I have always been firmly both feet in the operational, the applications
based, uh, camp.
Um, so I personally have, I wouldn't say none, but I have relatively little interest in getting
into that sort of minutia and databasing and all that sort of thing.
Um, my stance on it is, you know, as, as an operational tool, I just need to be correct.
We just, we need to be able to make the right call.
Um, so I don't particularly care, um, about the, the percentage of noise or the, the precise,
let's call it signal to noise ratio.
Obviously we want it to be good because at a certain point it's unusable as, but as long
as the signal to noise ratio is above a certain threshold for operational work, um, and it's,
and because we work team-based, it's very easy to filter out, uh, any remaining noise.
And so from that standpoint, um, it does not matter to me.
Uh, it doesn't really matter to my team and it certainly doesn't matter to the clients because
they care about the end result.
They just need the information.
So like two, two pieces of information that people should have or listening is, is one, um,
when you do isolated tests like that, you're talking about like, here's a target, give me
your information.
I'm going to grade it.
Right.
But that's not actually how the, the sessions are working because they're, um, particularly
with TRV, they're going back and refining the data when they see, um, information that's,
that's interesting.
They have people look closer at it.
They also, uh, use a team as opposed to one person.
So it's, um, a collective, right?
Uh, uh, an aggregate of the data as opposed to the individual.
So by dividing it and narrowly focusing on like, you know, um, what is the percentage of
like, we asked you to view a watermelon and how many times did you view the watermelon?
It's not really applicable to what they do.
There is someone that we're going to have on who is doing that, who is, um, collecting
that data.
His name is Chase McCarthy.
He's, um, uh, a young man who has put RV on the blockchain.
He, um, has socialrv.com and their data says that the viewers are right 51% of the time.
Now, okay.
Before anyone says, well, 51, 51 is statistically significant, but it's a small number, except
that they're letting everyone view, right?
So it's the 40% of people who can't really remote view and it's people who aren't very
good at remote viewing.
And so just generally, if you have the public, um, he's done about 20,000 sessions.
And if you have like everyone do it, it's right about 51% of the time.
It's significantly higher with his, um, super viewers.
He calls them.
Now his super viewers are not professional remote viewers.
So they're a tier below where they're like the highest ranking amateur viewers that he's
run into.
They would still not be the same.
The number that often gets thrown around is, um, depending on whom you ask, uh, between
65 and 85%.
Um, correct.
The, the, the viewers.
Now the, if, if anyone out there, like if Matt wanted to look into it further, or, uh,
if someone out there who's listening wants to look into it further, the, the person who
would really, or whose organization really tracks that is Lynn Buchanan, who was one of the
original viewers, uh, they have a style of RV that focuses on trying to find the perfect
viewer for each project.
So they track everything a viewer does and they find out like, does this, this viewer is
good at, uh, looking at cars.
Um, this viewer is good at looking at hostages and that viewer is good at looking at things
in space.
Like they're able to not just correlate the number of correct hits, but based on the subject
of viewer, they have these vast spreadsheets of data based on each viewer and how well each
viewer does against each type of subject.
So when someone goes to hire them, they say, well, um, you know, let's, this person wants
to look at an object in space.
Let's find out, you know, let's find who we have that does really well at looking at space,
but that's the heroic individual model.
Right.
And like, there's a, that definitely it's, it's strong.
It's like, um, a strong representation of American culture, but what like Morgan does, they work
in teams.
And, you know, no matter how good your viewer is, you can get the best viewer at looking
at space in the world, but he's not going to do better than a team over a certain period
of time.
It's the wisdom of the crowd, Fred Scalton, right?
Like we've known that since the 1700s, but depending on the mentality of the individual
involved, um, as a project manager or developing a different type of remote viewing, uh, there
are definitely like, um, there's definitely a cult of the heroic viewer there, but that isn't
what their technical remote viewing is doing.
So when Morgan says like, well, it's, it's not that important.
It's not that important because they work on, on a group level, right?
Like aggregate data.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Um, and there's, there's, well, since we're on the subject, um, you take the concept a
little further, uh, part of the issue with grading, um, a perception by perception record
of an RV session, um, as either, well, there are a couple of grades, but generally we, we rate
them as either correct, probably correct, can't feedback or incorrect.
So you can, you can get so far with that.
However, you start to run into an issue, um, especially when we're dealing with statistics
and, you know, if we're looking for something meaningful, well,
you can have sessions that are 100% correct, but they are in fact relatively ambiguous.
So for you use the example of, let's say your training target is, you know, remote view,
this watermelon.
Well, if I come back to you and I have a sketch of just something generally kind of oval shaped
and I have the perceptions of green, uh, hard, semi hard, and that's it.
That's my entire session.
Well, that, that is 100% correct.
However, am I, am I ever going to figure out that the target was a watermelon just from that?
No.
So there's actually, there's a secondary scale that, and again, I, this isn't, it's not an
area of my focus.
Um, I will, with students, I will occasionally, I will reference the scale and some, as I said,
you know, for a student, it's really, it's up to them how they choose to engage in, um,
in their own, like as, as an instructor, I grade their sessions in my own way.
If they want to, you know, go off and do their own database and that's fine.
They can do that.
Um, but, uh, you know, as I mentioned there, you can run into trouble this way, um, because
it, in some cases, you know, um, grading things like that can actually encourage a viewer not
to take the risk and not to push themselves, um, and work towards a place where they can actually
get specifics and detail regarding a target.
So there's actually a secondary grading scale that we use.
It's called the Targ scale.
And it was developed by one of the, uh, Stanford, uh, scientists, Russell Targ.
And it's basically a grade between one and seven, uh, or maybe it's zero and seven.
And I don't have it on me.
I have it on my computer, but basically, uh, a one, uh, a score of one is, and this is where
we get slightly more subjective, but a grade of one is that the session as a whole bears very
little resemblance, uh, to the target up to a seven where the viewer has named the, the specific
target in session, you know, a six correlating to a very, very strong, um, description, uh,
involving some uniquely identifiable components where the target could be through analysis
could be named, albeit not in the session.
Uh, if, if that kind of makes sense.
It makes sense to me.
What do you think, Matt?
Yeah, it makes sense.
I guess the reason I ask is I would just imagine if somebody were paying for the data, it would
be important to them to, to be sure that it was correct, right?
Because people might take action on, if the people take action on bad data, then, you know,
that's no good, but I don't, I don't, uh, I'm sure that there's, you have your methods
of, of making sure that that doesn't happen.
Um, yeah, so I guess I, I'm, I'm like, I'm ready to move on.
Um, thank you.
I guess I'll move on to the, the second prepared question, which I think we got into a little
bit, uh, when you were talking about sort of the study group, but the second question
is, um, what, what do you want people to know about how intuitive underground came together
and, and what you do?
So is, is there anything else that maybe we haven't touched on yet that, that you would
like to share to the public about what it is that intuitive underground is doing and how
you came together?
Well, I mean, yeah, we did, we did kind of touch on it, but, um, something I, I maybe should
suss out a little bit more is that, um, you know, generally speaking, the members of our
group, you know, I, I mentioned myself, I'm outside of RV.
I'm basically a layman.
I'm a bit of a jack of all trades, master of one.
Um, that's largely the case within our group.
So I, I guess I really just want to emphasize that, you know, you, you don't have to come
from a background of technical expertise, um, in order to get involved in remote viewing and
potentially, you know, if you're willing to toe the line to take it to a, a seriously workable
level.
Um, now that said, I mean, it takes, it takes hard work, no matter who you are.
Um, and in fact, there might even be a bit of a bell curve distribution there, um, in terms
of psychic ability and who has to work the hardest.
So the people that have to work the hardest to take, uh, trained, structured remote viewing
to a seriously workable level would be those probably with the least, uh, natural psychic
capabilities and those with the most, you know, it might seem counterintuitive, but, uh, it's
actually very, very difficult for a powerful natural psychic to conform, um, to the rigid
structure of, of a protocol and method, a system like technical remote viewing.
Um, so like I say, it sounds maybe counterintuitive, but the more you think about it, and especially
when you get involved, you can see pretty quickly why that might be.
And I've seen this many, many times, um, really, uh, adept natural psychics, just, they have
a hard time conforming to a rigid, uh, framework, you know, operating within that framework because
they're so used to just doing things their own way.
However, the advantage comes later, uh, when they, they do submit to a training regimen,
um, quite often they'll actually see, uh, market improvements, uh, in their work.
So really, um, I guess to kind of wrap up that line of thought, what we're doing with intuitive
underground, as I mentioned, is just to demonstrate what the average person, um, and beyond that,
what a group of average people can do, uh, when they get together, when they put in the work,
they put in the hours, the days, weeks, months, years, uh, and they stick together as a team,
there's, there's not a lot they can't, they can't do.
And, you know, as I mentioned that to me, that is, that's the type of individual empowerment
that a is sorely lacking.
And as a result of that is B sorely needed, uh, right now, you know,
all right, that sounds good.
Uh, thank you.
And I guess maybe to continue on that thread, uh, the last, uh, uh, prepared question is,
is what are the three most important things that people should know about your work?
Three most important things, like in terms of work that we've done, like some of our results
that's come out of the data.
Yeah.
Like what are the three as a remote viewer, you've seen a lot of things, you know, a lot
of things that other people don't know.
Uh, what are three things that, you know, that other people don't know that you want them
to know?
Right.
Okay.
Um, oh boy.
How about this?
Um, arguably the most important, I would say probably would be the work that we've done
into the nature of reality.
Um, and as it turns out, uh, uh, a big part of that is the death process.
Um, that's a whole subject that, uh, I mean, we've talked about it at length in other places
and I'll just, you, maybe, maybe this would be a good spot to give a plug to, uh, one of
your, one of your, uh, first spaces you ran in this, I don't know, this series of spaces
you've been running over the last, um, several years, I guess, at this point, a couple of
years, at least.
But, um, the first time that, uh, Dan and I, uh, publicly come out to talk about some of
this work was actually on, uh, JT space.
The name of the space is Bigfoot and it is still, um, it's available on, uh, JT's timeline.
I've actually directly linked to it on our website, uh, under the media section.
Um, so we got into, we got into this in, in pretty good detail there.
Um, so if anyone's interested in that, um, definitely recommend going back and having a
listen there.
But the reason, um, well, not just, uh, on its surface, but the reason I believe that work
actually has been delineated by our own higher minds, uh, as the most important work that
we've ever done, maybe that we ever could do was because of really how we stumbled across
that work.
And we really stumbled across this entire concept by running a, an experimental target.
One of our guys, uh, came up with this concept of trying to use RV to determine what was the
most important subject that we could use RV to look at.
So he came up with a targeting strategy and the target he designated was the most significant
remote viewing target.
So naturally that's asking the question, well, what's the most significant thing or, or subject
that we could use RV to look into.
And what came out of that was, again, this is a huge topic.
Like, so I'll try and summarize, uh, succinctly, but we basically had a, you can think of it
as almost like, like a storyboard, a sequence of events, um, beginning with, uh, let's just
say, uh, significant, uh, major earth changes, uh, whole shift type stuff, you know, big, uh,
big problems, big problems, big problems on old Terra.
Um, as a result of this, we, uh, we would expect to see mass death, mass die off in a short period of time.
And, okay, that's all standard enough.
Okay.
Well, where it starts to get a little, uh, little out there was the next part of the storyboard
that essentially described, uh, for lack of a better word, a harvest, a harvest of all the, uh,
the recently, those who recently found themselves without a body to inhabit.
And from there, we, we pursued this line of inquiry a little further.
And again, the, I'm, I'm summarizing, but the short version is that this led us to the concept of,
you know, what, what a lot of people refer to as the death trap, um, the kind of a forced reincarnation
cycle.
And from there, so it kind of leapfrogged because, you know, for each line of inquiry that you come
back with a solid answer for, uh, as often as not, that's going to highlight, you know, five more
questions that you didn't even know to ask five more lines of inquiry, you would have never thought
to pursue.
And so again, as a result of all this, we started looking into, um, the death process a little bit
closer, and we just kept coming back with corroborating results, whether we wanted them or not.
Um, the, the short version is that our work tells us the nature of reality is that the world
we, uh, appear to inhabit all of us collectively is no real world at all.
Um, it's something closer to, uh, the word, it's not perfect, but a simulation, um, but not
a purely digital simulation, like a, like a computer simulation, the, the kind we might think of
like an advanced version of the Sims or some, some video game.
It's kind of like that, but not quite.
There is in fact, a biological component to it.
And as such, the nature of the simulation actually is closer to a shared, uh, and a regulated
dream state that we are all in.
As though, you know, we exist elsewhere in a true base or prime physical reality.
And we appear to be all hooked up in some sort of a technological system that, you know, in
modern parlance, we might think of as something like a, a neural link, like Musk's neural link
system. Um, and that as a result of that, we are the biological components of the simulation.
Um, and for that reason, I, I, I've come to the word dream as probably the best or the closest
analogy that, um, that I could really use, um, in terms of the true, the ultimate nature of,
of this reality that we all occupy and, and perceive as, as real as all that there is.
So, I mean that, you know, as I said, that, that's an entire enormous subject that we could,
and we have talked about for hours and hours on end and still really only scratched the surface.
So, um, God, I hope I did an okay job of, of summarizing that huge concept.
No, I think you did a great job.
I think you did a great job.
Yeah. And, uh, I think that very eloquently put and, um, yeah, we've, we've definitely talked about it
before. We'll talk about it again. Um, it's an idea that, that once you, um, not accept it,
but if you accept it as a thought exercise, it informs every other thing you think about.
So, once you admit the possibility, um, that it's, that's true that we're in this collective dream
state, and this is, you know, this is the basis of every esoteric discipline, every school of
esoteric wisdom, you know, the majority of, uh, religions and, you know, it's a, it's a part of
Buddhism. It's a basic principle of Buddhism. It's a basic principle of Hinduism. And it was a basic
principle in antiquity and, you know, well-known to the Greeks who were supposed to be hyper-rational
people and, you know, the Gnosis, uh, the Gnostic community and the Manichaeans, and then up through
the different esoteric groups. And it's always been, um, groups of people who've talked about this
subject. Um, it just changes the way you think about everything once you acknowledge it, right?
Because then, um, everything isn't just, um, a physical thing. It's also a symbol. And that's
where you get like a lot of indigenous thought. And, but you know, those are, um, I think
something we flesh out in other, um, in other spaces and other podcasts and we'll, we will going
forward. I think, um, Matt actually had a great insight. Um, and that is, uh, you know, a circle
back. Like if, if we can't establish the certainty of prognostication, then, you know, people are
spending money, right? They're paying money for this information and they're going to act on this
information. And so like, how do we square that as prognosticators, like both on a moral and ethical
level that there are times when we're going to be wrong and people are going to act on, um, an incorrect
judgment. And also the, um, this sort of a, there are certain subjects that are, and we've, we've
explained the different reasons why these subjects are kind of like looked at differently from, you know,
prognostication is looked at differently. First of all, because 40% of people, you know, are completely
sensory, sensorially blind to it, right? Like 40% of people just, and, and many of them are very
successful people, right? So it's a 40% of people, but more than 40% of politicians and business leaders
and, and law enforcement officers and medical professionals, um, completely lack the, any type
of extracensory perception. And they also seem to lack what seems to be associated with extracensory
perception. That is like, uh, metacognition, theory of mind, empathy, you know, things that, that seem to
be attached to, um, extracensory perception in some way. So, um, we live in this world where we've got
very successful people thinking about things in a certain way, right? And if someone is going to pay
for, um, the insights of somebody who thinks about things in a different way, right? In a way that
isn't necessarily socially acceptable to everyone, like how do we address the fact that it's not going
to be a hundred percent accurate, right? Uh, I think in my opinion, it really doesn't come down to being
a hundred percent accurate, right? So I don't know if anyone out there who's, who's listening has had
medical issues, but you know, when you have surgeries and medical procedures, right, they're not a hundred
percent effective on a rare occasion. They are, but generally speaking, um, you're looking for 60%,
right? Or 80% would be a great outcome, right? Like if you, if you have a major injury and people,
because we don't really talk about that, um, as a society, people sort of assume the opposite,
right? Like they're like, well, that guy was injured and then that injury was healed and now
he's back. But people who've actually been through that know it's not true, right? Like we, you,
if you have a major injury, you're never a hundred percent, right? If your leg is crushed, it's never
the same. And if you see an athlete whose leg was crushed, who's back on the field, their leg was
never the same. It's just that they were an athlete, right? So we kind of accept this idea, but when it
comes to things like prognostication, you have to, um, look at it, like, what is the percentage,
in my opinion, what is the percentage of accuracy, uh, and insight from this data versus the percentage
of accuracy from commonly understood ideas, right? So the, the value of holding a, uh, of a virtue signal
of holding an idea that everyone else holds, isn't that that idea has been vetted to be accurate or
to be predict, predictably accurate, right? So that's sort of an assumption people make, but it's
not what it is, is, you know, we've talked about this in other spaces. So we'll talk about this in
the future, I guess, but you know, human beings are designed to, to want to be in the middle,
right? They want to affiliate, they want to associate. And it's, it's because, you know,
when we were like living in nature, um, where you are physically in relation to other people
determines your chances of survival. So at night, when everyone went to sleep, there are a few people
who are up top in a tree and there are a few people around the bottom of the tree. And there are people,
you know, in rings sort of in hots or whatever, right? Somebody is at the edge of the settlement.
And that person who's at the edge of the settlement is usually like a marginal individual. And that
individual is subject to more danger from, I don't know, invading communities, lions, tigers, floods,
whatever it is, um, that individual is, is more vulnerable. So human beings evolved, right? Uh, or
are designed, however you want to look at it to, um, want to associate how we think with how the group
things. And there are times when that really works. So like in a rising stock market, right? If the,
if the market is rising, if you're in a bull market and everyone is making money, then people who abstain
from investing at that time, uh, can, can lose a lot of money, right? There've been periods in our life.
Everyone here is old enough to remember that there were periods where everyone was making money.
And, um, you know, got to the point where like cab drivers would give everyone stock advice, right?
And then there's a crash. And so the thing is when you're with the majority, there'll be times when
everything goes well, and there'll be times when everything is a complete disaster. But the fact
that you're with everyone else provides a certain amount of security. It's also why people seek status
in societies, right? Because if you are a higher status individual with financial resources and you don't
need the financial resources are important, right? But the status is more important. If you are central
to a social network, if you are a high status individual, if you have money, your status and
your money are the solution to your problems. There's a solution to your medical problems. Oftentimes
that a solution to your marital problems. Oftentimes there's a solution to your, um, whatever it is,
right. If you have a question, you can hire somebody to answer that question for you. So if somebody were
to say like, how do we compare, um, the, the opinion of a remote viewer and astrologer or prognosticator
with the opinion of a successful person online, right? The problem with that comparison is the, the reason
that person is successful is because they have been able to, um, elevate themselves above, above other
people. They have been able to make themselves socially central to the community. That's how they have
their status, right? Like if someone comes out and says, I'm a workout bro. And I take hundreds of
peptides and my testosterone is optimized. I'm going to show you how to do it. Right. Like someone else
comes out and says, yeah, I've made $80 million. I'm going to show you how to get rich. Right. And then,
you know, someone else is out there and they're like, yeah, I've slept with 5,000 women and I can help
you do it too. You know, the thing is it's very seductive. And oftentimes if you pay them,
if you spend money, uh, for their advice and the data they have to offer you, you will receive
some helpful data, but you will never receive, uh, the type of data that you believe you're going
to receive. You'll never receive the type of help that you believe you're going to receive because
no one gets rich by empowering other people to be rich. Uh, you can sell programs, right? But not by
making people rich, right? No one gets rich by, um, or no one gets, uh, yeah, rich by, um,
really teaching everyone else to be a competitive bodybuilder, right? To, by creating their competition,
no one, uh, succeeds relative to other people by elevating other people to their own level.
It's actually, it's oxymoronics. It's impossible, uh, for that to happen. Right. Um, in order to be
the top of 10 people, everyone else has to be beneath you. So it definitely seems like there's this
information out there. And if you pursue the information, um, on, on the internet or on social
media, find the right person to give you a, uh, uh, an opinion, then you're going to, to figure out
the right way to do something. But as you get older, you realize that that's not true. Um, and oftentimes
the best you're hoping for is better than 50%. So, uh, I don't know about the modern AI research. I don't
know where we're at right now. Um, in the past, they, when they were first putting together computer
algorithms, they would, um, look at, uh, and the wisdom of the crowd, right? Like, um, decentralized sort
of Kalishi or whatever that is, or, um, these, these markets, the futures markets. So when they
were looking at that, they would say, um, going back to the very beginning, I Francis called and
they would say 100 people is their combined understanding of anything is always going to
be correct relative to any expert. And that's not like, uh, what they all think they're supposed
to say, but if you ask their independent opinions, so you're not talking about like the, um, the
virtue signals of the crowd, you're talking about the wisdom of the crowd. And they said,
well, uh, with an expert versus an algorithm, an expert is the best experts in the world to
write about 51% of the time. And algorithms can often be right more than that. So I think
computer algorithms, if they're well-made or a great source of data, but I think that most
people don't recognize that the greatest experts in the world in their fields are generally considered
to be the greatest experts because they're right about 51% of the time. So when you get
into a prognosticator, uh, something like, uh, remote viewing or astrology, if you, if you
find someone who is an expert in those subjects, if the data they're able to give you is 65%
correct. And I think it's higher than that. I think like a really great remote viewing team
is about 85%, right? But that even that doesn't show the exact truth because there are times when
they're going to know they didn't hit the target. And so those are all combined. The times they know
they didn't hit the target and the times they, they know they did. There are times when like
they're on target and the data is very, very correct. Right. As somebody who's like in the
market, if somebody is looking to hire a remote viewer and you say, well, I've got this important
question. Is it worth my money if they're not going to be correct a hundred percent of the time? Well,
you have to say, well, what are your other sources of information? Right. So in, I think we're going
back, it was 2021. I think Morgan, maybe 2022, but I think it was 2021 you were saying when they did
the ramifications for the vaccine. Now that's, that's controversial, right? Because there are a lot
of people who don't want to accept that there's any health ramifications to that medical treatment.
And I think that that number is getting smaller all the time, but those, those people are out there
and they're like very vocal. Right. And it's probably still a majority, to be honest.
The majority still disagrees with that information, but that information was highly predictive, right?
And people are seeking those medical treatments right now. So if you had paid for that information,
right, let's say you were looking to develop a treatment. If it was 2020, 2021, and you had paid
Intuitive Underground for that information, you would have 100% accurate information about what the
treatments that are being developed today for that illness is for that, the ramp, that, um,
the side effects of that treatment, regardless of whether you believe it's true or not,
because you'd be looking at, you know, what are the, what are the treatments going to be? Right.
So like, if you were looking to make money, if you were saying like, I'm an investor and I want to
know like what to invest in, what are people going to be, you know, what treatments are people going to be
seeking based on the exposure to this experimental medical treatment? You would have been a hundred
percent dead on. If you invested in colloidal metals and this dialysis process, you would have been
ahead of the curve. Now, I don't know how much money you would make. I don't know how big it's going to
be. Right. So it really comes down to judging the information you have. And I think that's,
that's where it's often like where we're not, we hold people to standards and we should,
but we don't often think about the accuracy of the other information in our lives. So it's
definitely true that if you go to see a remote viewer, an astrologer, a prognosticator, you can't
guarantee the accuracy of the information. You cannot guarantee they hit the target. You cannot
guarantee the information is a hundred percent accurate. And as a matter of fact, as time goes on,
because the mind looks to disprove things, you're going to find reasons or examples,
uh, or details in which the information is not completely accurate, but it really comes down to
how accurate the average person's beliefs are at any given time. And that's very inaccurate. That's less
than 50%. So not everyone here. Cause everyone here is amazing. Right. But if you go out into X right
now on any subject, the average person, including people who post on it repeatedly, um, ad nauseum,
right, is less than 50% accurate about everything. Generally speaking, less than 40% or even 30%
accurate about everything. So generally speaking, if you go out there right now, you're going to find
people, even who claim to be experts who, you know, if they're, if 30% of their posts are true
and accurate, that is an accomplishment. So I just wanted to put that out there so that we all
understand, like, it is true that, you know, if you're asking people to purchase a service and then
you're saying, or, you know, it's even further because Morgan wants people to learn RV and you're
saying like, well, if I learn RV, am I going to be a hundred percent right? No. I mean, you,
you might be in the 30% correct category. Right. And that might be where you, where you,
you, the ceiling is for you. Um, the question is what about everyone else?
So you're really looking for an advantage, right? And when it comes to people who, who work with
astrologers or learn astrology, people who work with remote viewers or learn remote viewing,
they're looking for a greater advantage relative to their peers. And, uh, that's really the question.
And does the information, um, that one receives from hiring remote viewer, an astrologer or learning
remote viewing and astrology, give one a relative advantage to their peers is 100% certainty with
that. Absolutely. Now, when you talk about like, well, uh, what about rich people, right? Do they use
it? Yeah. I mean, they do, but they don't often talk about it for a number of reasons, right? They
don't want the social stigma and they definitely don't want, um, competition, you know, however,
when you look into the lives of wealthy people, you often find that they hire astrologers or they've
learned astrology themselves. Uh, there's that often, um, repeated JP Morgan quote, millionaires
don't hire astrologers, billionaires do. But when you're, uh, when you're an experienced astrologer,
you learn to recognize when people are doing things on certain dates. So you recognize that like this
administration, you know, always uses certain lunar cycles to announce news, for instance, or when I
used to work in hotels years ago, I would notice that, uh, one of the companies that I worked for,
like they would always open new hotels. Um, and, uh, you know, um, they were Asian. So that's,
um, that's one of the reasons like they, everything they did was timed by astrology. And if you weren't
astrology, you wouldn't recognize that. Um, now with remote viewing, do wealthy and successful people
hire remote viewers? And the answer there is there were a lot of remote viewers. So Morgan is here talking
to you guys. And if you go on like the remote viewing discord or remote viewing groups, you're going to run
into people, 90% of them are not operational remote viewers. They're people who are interested in the
subject. The reason that you don't run into the operational remote viewers is because they're working. But when
you research hiring an operational remote viewer, you find that there are many organizations out there right
now, many of them. So like how many dozens? Yes. Hundreds, maybe not. So anywhere between dozens and
hundreds of organizations. And they work for, you know, they work under NDAs. They were classified for,
um, corporations, for politicians, for the government. We have, um, you know, Morgan's very open.
There's sometimes he can't talk about, you know, what he's doing. Right. But he's very open with
the type of work he does as a remote viewer. We have people who come on like, um, people in our X
circle, a buddy alien protocols. He works for corporations and he has for years worked for
corporations as, um, as a, there's a certain term, some sort of research. They have a technical term
that they hide remote viewing under. So people with money and people who have a lot of information,
right? Look at remote viewing as a, as a valid tool for gaining information. I'll give you another
example. Um, we have these whistleblowers in the UFO X community, right? Everyone loves the
whistleblowers. Oh, what's happening here. Are you doing this guys? This is me. Oh, sorry. I just
I just said we're running into a time check. I mean, we are running. Are you? Absolutely.
Do you want to keep going for a few minutes because no one's listening to our podcast yet
anyhow. So we're trying to perfect that, but I just wanted to get through this point, but
you're right. Um, it is, we were trying to do 90 minutes and under because that's what's
successful for podcasts. But as of right now, we don't really have any podcast listeners,
so I'm not super concerned about it, but thank you for letting me know. Uh, I pretty much thought
that was just like a random thing that was happening. Um, or that one of the people like
in the listeners had the ability to do it. Anyhow, um, I get confused easily. So, um, yeah, buddy
and a professional remote viewing and, um, yes. So, uh, we know the government has remote
viewing programs. We know that DARPA has remote viewing programs, right? But what we, when
that subject comes up and they say, well, some of the remote viewing programs came public
and some of them went dark, what that ignores is the number of people who are coming out
of the defense department, um, talking about other subjects who also, um, refer to themselves
or claim to be trained remote viewers. So two of the number one whistleblowers, quote unquote,
whistleblowers in ufology who might not be whistleblowers, right? Like Lou Elizondo is a trained
remote viewer. And not only that, but he talks about working for Hal Puthoff when he was in
Guantanamo doing remote viewing experiments with other remote viewers and remote influencing
experiments on Guantanamo Bay, uh, prisoners after nine 11. So people might not take Lou as
seriously as they ought to, right? But that was a very serious place at that time. Like Guantanamo
Bay is a serious place. That was a very serious place at that time. The war against terror
was the central focus of our society. And at the very center of the central focus of our
society was a remote viewing program doing research. And one of those remote viewers has
emerged and taken over the UFO, right? The discussion in the UFO community. Another one is Richard
Doty. Richard Doty is a trained remote viewer. So you have these individuals coming out of the
defense department who worked in counterintelligence and intelligence, anti-terrorism, counterterrorism,
talking about being trained remote viewers, right? You've got groups of remote viewers who work for
the FBI following nine 11. Um, that's where Prudence Calabrese went, uh, lover or hater. And John
Vivananko who works for metaphysical right now, um, or runs a TV show for rise.tv and works in
the metaphysical TV show. Like they, they worked for the FBI after nine 11. So I guess it comes down to
like, if you have to be, if you only have some money and you have to be a hundred percent certain,
then hiring a prognosticator is probably not for you. Like if it's like, this is my one bet
and I've got this, this money. And when this money's gone, it's gone. Like that's serious. And
if somebody approached me like that, because people have approached me in the past. And the first thing
I've asked them is, are you on a limited income? Right? Because sometimes, well, not all the time,
but it is, there is a strong chance sometimes when you work in this, that you're dealing with someone
who's on a limited income, um, because there's great uncertainty and vulnerability in their life.
And, um, you know, something like astrology or remote viewing provides them with insurance. Right. That
they information and data that wouldn't be able to get anywhere else. Um, and if somebody were to come
to me and say, look, uh, you know, I, I don't have much money and, um, you know, but I need to make an
important decision. Like I might, you know, ethically, I, I might like really step back and say,
I don't know ethically if I want to do this. Right. But generally speaking, you're dealing with
people who have other sources of information and they're looking at you as like an additional
source of information or a superior source of information. And I take 65 to 85% any day,
um, over anything else. Right. Like if, if you, if you hit 85% of your stock picks, you would be
like five times the investor that Nancy Pelosi is. And she's the greatest investor in history. And let's
not get into the other details about that. It is a fact that she is the greatest investor
in history, regardless of, of how that came to pass. Right. So yeah, I think people just
have to make the decision based on, on, on, on those assumptions. Um, but it's definitely
not a hundred percent. I don't know anything that is. Um, but what do you think like now,
like what, what percentage would make it like a valuable data source versus percentage that
wouldn't, and I'm asking sincerely, like what, what's your thinking in this subject?
Yeah. Well, I, I, yeah. I, so I, I didn't assume that it would be a hundred percent. Um,
that's why I asked first if we tracked what the hit rate was. Um, right. So I would say,
yeah, like if we're going to go with the stock analogy, I mean, anything over 51%, you'd make
a ton of money. Right. Like, I mean, if you had, uh, if we're flipping a coin and it was weighted
towards heads and you had, you know, a bunch of money and bet a hundred dollars in every flip,
you'd make a killing. So it, it sort of depends, I think on the data, right? Like if you're going
to make, if you're going to pay for a hundred, um, predictions, right. And you're going to take
action on, on a hundred predictions, then anything over 50% short would be great. But if you're going
to make one prediction, then yeah, like, I guess like if you trust that, oh, okay, that's going to
like 65% accurate, then that's fine. Right. Like we trust doctors, like you're saying, but like a 60%,
um, successful surgery. Um, but I think a lot of people who might be interested in paying for a service
might not like trust the figure necessarily, unless it's backed up by some kind of data. And so that's
why I think it's, it's helpful to have a track record, right. Of like, these are the predictions
that, that we've made and, and these were the successful and, and be upfront about the fact
that it's not accurate all the time. Um, so that's sort of what I was, I was getting at, uh, a while
ago, but we have our, our distant cousin on, uh, chase. Um, he is like, so there are, there are
definitely people who look at it from that perspective. Right. So one thing is, uh, remote
viewers, I think astrologers are actually more money minded. Remote viewers tend to be very art artsy
types like musicians and artists. It seems to be the primary, um, psychological or, or, or neuro
form of neurodiversity that is attracted to remote viewing. And, um, with rare exceptions, not very
materialistic people. So, um, I can think of one individual in all of remote viewing that I know for
certain, um, two, two, I can think of two individuals in all of remote viewing who I know for certain are
like really trying to make as much money as possible out of thousands. Uh, it just isn't the, um, the way
that people think who get involved in, um, remote viewing. There are, like I said, there are two, uh,
specific individuals who are really trying to make as much money as possible, but they don't tend to be
materialistic or money minded people. So it's hard to say, like, cause people say, well, if, uh, if that
works, you know, why aren't you rich? The people who get involved in remote viewing aren't people who are
going to be rich, um, or really have any interest in it, but it's hard to make that case with people,
right? Because if someone is really money minded, then, um, you know, they're not necessarily going
to believe that's true. They're going to think like, well, the person I'm dealing with just isn't
very good or it's not really, uh, that accurate. Now there are other people who like, they really
want to prove that sigh is, is valid. And like for most of us who have gotten to this level and I'm,
I'm not a remote viewer. I want to be clear about that, but I associate remote viewers, right? A lot of,
some of my best friends are remote viewers. And, um, like when you get to this, this point, um,
you don't have any doubt, uh, or at least I don't have any doubt. I followed the remote viewing
community since the 1990s, since Ed first started going on the radio. Like I don't have any doubt
about the effectiveness. I've seen session after session, prediction after prediction,
after prediction. So it never even occurs to me to have doubt, but there are people who like really
want to get into it with the statistics. Right. And I think that that's going to chase is going to be,
you know, when he comes on social rv.com, it's going to be really good because that's what he's done.
He's he has taken the RV sessions and tied the predictions to the blockchain in the understanding,
I guess, because I'm not a blockchain guy, as you can probably tell that those predictions are now
going to be around forever. So like, I think he's the person who's really going to get into,
be able to get into the numbers and keeping track. And, um, at some point his methodology may
be widely adopted, you know, he's young and, um, what he's doing is popular. And there's, you know,
there's no reason why, um, to imagine that in 10 years or 20 years, everyone won't use the same
methodology and be able to look at the blockchain and say, you know, my prediction rate is 64% or
whatever, or the average person who's trying, it would probably be someplace in the thirties.
I'm not really certain if that's accurate, but I, that's my, my gut is telling me that. So my hunch
is like the average person, if they're capable of ESP is probably in the thirties. Um, even with some
training again, that's like 30% more, right? If you could see 30% of the time, you could remote view
beside behind closed doors. Right. And I'm not saying that like, from the sense of like being a creep,
but I'm saying like 30% of the time you could answer questions for yourself that no one else can
answer. Like what's in Antarctica and you know, uh, you know, what, what type of performance appraisal
is my boss going to give me? Um, that would be worth it to me that that's like, I would think that's
a good investment, but definitely when it comes to like the really powerful remote viewers, um,
not, you know, not powerful, like, uh, like, uh, uh, comic book hero, but just really effective
and efficient remote viewing. I think that, uh, it's a lot higher than that. Morgan, what else do
you got? We're going to kind of wrap it up. Cause as Matt says, like we're over our time because
I was on a rant about, you know, about RV and why it's worthwhile, even though it's not a hundred
percent effective. Um, I didn't mean to hijack it, but you know, that's a known issue with me. So, uh,
you have any comments, questions, concerns, or anything you'd like to add?
Oh, sorry. Were you asking me? Yeah. You Morgan, you're Morgan. Oh, I'm just, I'm sorry. I know
I didn't, I didn't hear my name. Um, Morgan's a great name and you know, I, I wish more people
were named Morgan, but you're the only Morgan here in this race. Apparently it means born by the sea.
Really? Oh shit. Huh? Well, that's at least one meaning. All right.
Multiply. So there you go. Yeah. Well, I mean, I, I'm the discount version. I was born near a lake.
Anyhow. Um, no, just, uh, I'll say, uh, largely, I think I agree with, uh, pretty much everything
you said there. Um, just to really briefly wrap it up, uh, Matt, maybe, um, maybe this will add a little
bit, hopefully, um, to, uh, answering that question, um, statistics and all that aside. So
what there are, there are a number of, uh, points along the, the process of removing from project
conception through completed analysis and, and a submitted report, um, each designed to filter out,
uh, potential, uh, noise, right. Improve that signal to noise ratio. Um, with our published work,
one of them, of course, the ultimate decider is at the, at the end of a project. If we're not satisfied,
um, that we have a reliable result, we simply won't, we will never go to publication. Right. Um, now
in a contract scenario, we don't really have that option. We have to submit our results. Um,
regardless. So in such a case, which has happened, but not that often, um, but we, you know, we will,
we'll caveat that, Hey, look, this is not necessarily, um, the highest reliability.
Um, but yeah, I'm trying to, that very seldom happens. And again, one of the advantages is
working with, with a team, not just, you know, one individual viewer, right. That alone, you know,
um, increases the likelihood of actionable results significantly right there. And in addition to all
the other, uh, filtration steps that we take, um, kind of a slight aside to that is there's also the
possibility that the individual, uh, who has received the results for whatever reason, they don't,
they don't like the results and they refuse to take action on them. Um, you know, without getting,
uh, too specific, I will say, um, at least once I can think of, I got probably a good example of that
would be, um, the results that it was, uh, a kind of a personal insights type project that
we were working for someone and it, we specified a, a particular, um, interpersonal relationship
dynamic between this individual and a family member, a specific family member.
Um, and the long and short of it is, you know, when, when we submitted these results, the,
the person was, uh, I might not go so far as to say apoplectic, but they were not happy and they
absolutely, they, they simply refused to, to take action. Um, so at that point, it's kind of out of,
out of our control. Um, and a little maybe further that point is I would, I would warn everyone, um,
be cautious of any, whether they're just, you know, your everyday psychic medium or, or a professional
team of remote viewers or acclaimed self-proclaimed team of professionals, be wary of any team who tells
you that they've never had a client displeased with the results because that's an instant ragged flag to
me right there. And that tells me that they're very likely. And then this is a known phenomenon
in, uh, in, uh, psychic work and remote viewing. Um, if, if you haven't trained and, and gained enough
experience, what can happen is the person can come up with psychic information that is basically what
the client wants to hear. Okay. And that happens. I've seen that happen and it's, it's, it's something
that, uh, an operator can train themselves not to do, but very few actually do that. And hence the
warning, you know, if a psychic or remote viewer tells you that they've never had a client, uh,
displeased with their work, then it's very likely that's what they're doing. They're just giving them
the fluffy results that they want to hear, which at the end of the day, that's no better than a cold read.
Well, that's great. That's a, that's a great point. I'm going to tell everyone for the record.
And, uh, like people don't need to know the details of individuals, uh, friendships or whatnot,
but you know, when your friend does something for a living, right, like it's, it's bad form to ask them
for free shit. Okay. So, uh, I don't, I don't tend to do that. And, and so I just want to let everyone
know my level of confidence is such that, uh, I, myself, you know, I was in an accident years ago.
I had a bunch of, um, negative, uh, effects, like not side effects, like complications over
the course of a couple of years. And I'm kind of looking at entering a new chapter of my life right
now. We've got some stuff going on. I'm looking forward to, so I myself am saving up, right.
To hire a remote viewer to look at my medical situation and just give me a sense of like,
what I might want to, um, focus on. Right. And I will be, when that happens, I'll be working through
Morgan to find that individual, those individuals. All right. So I have enough confidence in it myself,
having seen the details, including like when they do medical readings to know that there's that value
in it. So like, I, I'm not just, um, boosting him cause he's my friend. Right. Um, the, uh,
but it's definitely not, it's, you know, it's when you hire like these professional remote viewers,
you're not going to a $50 psychic. Right. So it does cost more money and it should because of the
level of accuracy and the scientific rigor, um, applied to the process, whether you believe it's
scientific process. Right. Uh, the other thing is a little housekeeping. Um, I have decided that it's,
we have a goal and our goal is, uh, that I would like the podcast to be at contact in the desert in
2027, uh, June 3rd through 7th. Now I'm not saying that's going to happen, right? Goals. You don't
always reach your goals, but that is like, we're in the early stages right now. We're just getting going,
we're warming up where we're getting used to talking to each other. And, um, my, my goal is to be at that
level of, uh, a success to, to be out there at the contact in the desert, um, and running a podcast,
uh, uh, from there at that time. So, um, yeah, I just wanted to let everyone know that we have a goal.
And also I myself like believe in the RV data enough that I'm willing to put my money where my mouth is.
I have hired a remote viewer in the past. Uh, I can't talk about all the details. Um,
but I have all myself hired a professional remote viewer to answer or to, um, for some pertinent
information. I'm not exactly certain, uh, uh, in that case, what I'm supposed to talk about what
I'm not supposed to talk about. So I just try to avoid talking about the whole thing, but I can tell
you that, that I do, um, I, I do believe in it, uh, like very firmly that it's a, it is a, uh,
it gives you a significant advantage. And the data that I received from that, um, was priceless
in my opinion. Uh, that's what I've got, Matt, you want to wrap it up and thank you everyone
for coming and listening. Yes. Thank you everybody. Thank you, uh, Morgan for coming and speaking.
Uh, it was very helpful for me. I, I don't know that much about remote viewing. Um, and so I just
want to clarify that my, my questions aren't intended to be, uh, skeptic, but just, you know,
curious. And so I just wanted to thank you, Morgan for, uh, for coming on and, and, and,
you know, allowing us to interview you and talk about your work. And it was very interesting.
So thank you. Oh, and, uh, thanks for having me on guys. Thanks, Matt. And thanks JT.
Um, and, uh, Hey, look, just, uh, maybe a little aside to that. Yeah. Okay. So if anyone, uh, actually
wants to, uh, look at it in a little more depth, um, uh, gain a little more depth of
understanding about, uh, what RV as a practical skill looks like, um, I have a free, uh, training,
but I wouldn't necessarily consider it. Uh, it's not a full fledged training course, obviously,
but it's, uh, it's a, basically it's a primer booklet. It's about a 50 page booklet and it is,
uh, freely available on my site. Uh, no, uh, you don't even have to sign up for, uh, you know,
a mailing list or anything like that. Um, it's just, you can just a free, uh, zip download and,
yeah, it's, it's, sorry. You should drop the site when you say that, you know, tell them what the site is.
Oh yeah, sure. Sure. Sure. It's, uh, remote viewing training.com and JT for future reference.
If you, if you can't remember if it's that or learn remote viewing.com, uh, I also, I actually own the
domain, just my name.com. I own Morgan Farrell.com and that just directly to the training site.
So that's a known issue with me. I, I I'm 50% wrong on that. Yeah, that's true.
So anyhow. Yeah. If anyone wants to, to have a look at that, like I say, it's just, it's, uh,
I think there's a button right at the top of the page and, and besides that there's a contact form
on there. Um, so you can, uh, you know, reach out at any time, uh, by email. Um, anyhow. Yeah.
Yeah. Thanks. Uh, thanks again, guys. Thanks for having me on. Uh, it was enjoyable.
Okay. Hey, Matt, thanks for, um, for running things and asking questions. They're good questions.
They're questions I wouldn't ask myself that definitely need to be addressed. And there's
nothing wrong with being skeptical. It's being skeptical. Not that I'm saying you are, but being
skeptical is good. Um, and Morgan, thanks for coming on everyone. We're going to, um, we're
going to wrap it up, but we'll be back next week. And I think we'll be talking about something
astrology themed. Um, but you know, I'm not exactly certain. So, um, everyone have a good night.
There's gonna be like a 15 second pause. And again, thank you for, um, coming by and listening.